for the martial arts training portion of
this video Adam is very calmly asked me
to provide some of my expertise so to
start with it's important to note that
Bruce Lee himself said that his physique
was more as a result of his martial arts
training which was his primary goal
rather than for purely aesthetics
however there are numerous accounts from
friends and people that knew Bruce
recalling how he was very proud of his
physique and would often show people
different muscles that have been
developing so there are some elements of
that in there as well now the things I'm
going to be including here will be
mainly centered around improving martial
arts performance explosiveness and legit
a it's important to develop a fine
balance and not focus too heavily upon
purely strength and conditioning as
somebody who's training for a sporting
type activity like Bruce was himself and
this is a really good clip of Conor
McGregor here talking about Bruce and
comparing him to some of today's stiff
and overly conditioned fighters I've no
doubt he would have been war champion in
MMA know them he's fluid he's loose he's
fast his movement is fluid its efficient
it's functional so many guys were
addicted the strengthen conditioner was
get balled up and stiff and slow and
Bruce was free
his body was nimble Bruce made a major
change to his training philosophy after
the 1964 fight with Wong Jack man
primarily from building upon the Wing
Chun style he felt although he'd won
that fight his performance was not a
crisp but nor efficient and that by the
end of the fight it was considerably
winded signifying to himself that he was
far from in perfect condition and this
is the point when he began to dissect
and create his own way in the form of
Jeet Kune Do and also since that year
there's a distinct change in Bruce's
appearance as he began focusing heavily
upon cardiovascular training on top of
his martial arts work I feel that
Bruce's interval training for the
martial artist program that's featured
in the art of expressing the human body
to be spot-on actually so this was
Bruce's own personal program according
to the book and I really like this it
included a lot of very important
elements and you can really make this
your own as well
Lee defined strength is the ability of
the body to exert great force while
power as the ability to release an
explosive force to produce a quick
sudden movement of the body with maximum
effort and power also involves the rate
of speed at which the force is
expressing itself in other words power
is the marriage of strength and velocity
is one thing to build strength through
weight training but another to be able
to have your bod
apply power in the right amount and with
the right timing even the best
techniques are useless if you don't have
the power to execute them effectively
this is where the laymen myth continues
to flourish in that people with large
muscles must be able to strike
powerfully by default by way of their
size which is false so in order to
develop this we'll be using the age-old
heavy back for the main portion of the
upcoming program however a word of
caution on becoming too overly confident
as a result of continually using the
heavy back a live opponent is not going
to stun there and allow you the luxury
of for preparation keep moving as if
you're facing a real person holding your
guard high as you train moving in and
out with rapid footwork practicing head
movement and not overly lunging in with
your strikes the heavy bag is an amazing
tool but the way you can hit the bag is
not the way you can hit a moving
opponent so be mindful of what it's used
for and its limits so now we're going to
take a look at the sample training
program that I've put together so first
we've got the warm-up which consists of
jump rope and agility ladder next we
have the shadow box in rounds one of
them is a warm-up and the second is more
intense maintaining good form throughout
sometimes Bruce was known to split his
training days in two hand and leg
technique days so we're doing that here
as well so for one of the martial arts
training days you'll do the boxing
rounds and for the other one you will do
the kickboxing rounds and all of these
rounds are for three minutes with a
one-minute rest in between I've outlined
five on here but I recommend five to
eight rounds if you wish to make it a
bit longer now this is just a sample
program that I've put together you can
follow it exactly or perhaps change
things out a little by switching some of
the rounds for sparring up hard work the
way to get the most out of this workout
is to hit the heavy bag with real intent
meaning to continually push yourself to
get better and better and condition
yourself in this way one of the simplest
but most overlooked ways of improving
your explosiveness is simply by forcing
your body to move quickly again and
again and again as you strike so now
we'll begin the workout to warm up we're
just going to be doing jump rope for
five to ten minutes start slowly and
then build up to a moderate pace now
jump rope is great for coordination and
footwork and it can also be used to
build stamina as well if you want to do
it more intensely if you're proficient
with using a jump rope then you can try
all different types of movements and
footwork patterns but if it's something
that's new for you just stick to
maintaining a basic rhythm throughout
until you've worked up a light sweat
[Music]
so also included as part of the warm-up
is the use of the agility ladder which
is a tool I really really like to use
this is something I always like to start
with because it's really good for
improving your agility and explosiveness
as well which are keys in martial arts
training rather than trying to explain
all of the different things I'm doing
here it's probably best you just watch
them they're quite self-explanatory
what you want to do here is you want to
do each of these exercises all the way
through and then repeat it again two to
three times getting faster on each round
the key things that you want to make
sure of here are that you're not taking
too big steps too far away from the
ladder so you're not wasting too much
energy you want to try and get that
movement as quick and as efficient as
possible
this is an example of media and all the
exercise is a little bit quicker than
the first time and if you're going at
this speed you should really feel it
start to burn your carves which is going
to improve your explosiveness
[Music]
these are just some simple dynamic
swings to prepare our body for the main
part of our heavy back workout I don't
personally like to do a super extensive
warm-up with loads of stretching when I
start just because I kind of prefer to
warm up as I go but if you've got loads
of injuries and stuff like that you
might want to do a little bit more
[Music]
firstly we have the shadowboxing rounds
when done correctly shadowboxing can
have huge benefits on many elements of
training including technique speed
endurance and footwork for this first
round we're just going to be loosening
off the body but maintaining good
economical form or economy of motion
this is something to really be mindful
of throughout the upcoming training as
well it means always keeping the
technique crisply tight even during warm
brands or good technique is a result of
a lack of refinement and more energy has
been expended than is needed resulting
in a slow and clunky technique energies
being discharged through unnecessary
exertion and then correction and this
can be overcome by understanding the
bodily mechanics and repetition of the
time
[Music]
for the second round we're going to pick
up the pace and push ourselves remain
completely relaxed to throw your
techniques cleanly and explosively when
performing combos be sure to fully
extend the strikes and not cook them
short in favour of speed and weaken in
their potential
[Music]
so for round one we're going to do
straight punches only so this can be any
combinations of jab cross jab jab cross
for straights and so on as you can see
I'm not throwing full power and full
speed all the time I do throw it
intervals and then move around the bag a
little bit practicing head movement to
footwork as well so you want to keep
moving the whole time don't think you
have to just stand in one place and just
smash the bag by no means though is this
an invitation to take it easy
Bruce noted in his own writings that you
should continually push yourself and I
agree with that sentiment 100% I think
so many martial artists fail to progress
quickly because they just aren't putting
enough intensity into their training so
you can see what I'm doing here this is
a good level for me and you can adapt
that to your own training as well
round number two nice and simple same
thing but we're just going to be adding
in hook punches
and we're gonna be adding body shots and
level changes now onto that so coming
down to the stomach area utilizing those
liver shots it's a really important shot
to practice because when done correctly
and powerfully a liver shot can
completely incapacitate an opponent and
end a fight as it's often seen in boxing
matches
so now for round four will gonna be
adding in elbows and other hand
techniques as well so this might look a
little bit strange but what i'm doing
here is some things from all different
types of styles so some tail bows
there's also some stuff from filipino
trapping in here as well which is what
later became part you kundo as well
and round number five the last round is
just any and all hand technique so it's
a freestyle round and you want to pick
up the pace a little bit on this one and
push yourself
so for round number one we're gonna do a
simple five hit combination and that
consists of jab cross hook hook low rear
round kick now I'm doing the hooks at
different positions on here so you can
do them head height and body height or
you can do two body hooks and so on if
you can see as well I don't always throw
the combination so I'm not just doing
the combo then doing the combo again
sometimes I do it and then sometimes
I'll move around and throw some of the
random techniques and then I'll go into
the combination again but essentially
I'm working upon that one combo
throughout this round
this round I'm working an 11 hit
combination the moves that I'm doing
here are jab split entry which is where
you Parian strike simultaneously cross
lead low round kick cross hook cross
real around kick double jab cross now
you don't have to follow this exact
combination it's just an example but
just remember the principle that you
want to implement a long combination for
this round
and this one similarly is a 10 hit
combination it looks similar to the
other one but it's actually different so
the techniques that I'm doing are jab
cross hook jab cross
shuffle lead leg round kick cross hook
cross rear leg round kick I like doing
long combinations like this just because
it conditions you to move up more of a
fighting pace and train your body to
move in intense bursts for longer
periods of time
the nice and simple round that doesn't
need much explanation it's just power
kicks so make sure you've got a lot of
intention behind these kicks
and just like with the last box in round
we're now doing a completely freestyle
kickboxing round so using all different
types of techniques and just like before
as well keep the pace nice and high
I hope you enjoyed this video and if you
did please follow me on Instagram I've
got a lot of different training clips on
there and also you can send me a message
if you need any help with the workout in
the video so the full building Bruce
program looks like this other things to
consider make sure you warm up
thoroughly before every workout and get
plenty of recovery time and rest in
between aim to eat a balanced and
nutritious diets aiming for maintenance
calories and consume about one gram of
protein for every one pound of
bodyweight to support muscle growth and
to avoid becoming too lean finally
should incorporate some kind of warm-ups
and mobility training into this routine
for improving mobility and flexibility
do your static stretches at the end of
each workout not at the beginning use
any routine for your stretching cooldown
but I've shared a few in my Nightwing
training and in the Batman Begins
program to check those out if you want
something ready-made so thanks ton for
watching guys I hope you found this
video useful and interesting if you did
then please leave a like share around
there helps me out immensely comment
down below and let me know what you
think of this program if there's
anything I missed and of course they
tuned hit subscribe if you want more
like this there's lots of cool stuff on
the way soon including another Batman
program yeah thanks a ton for watching
this one and bye for now